I think it's still hitting me, the fact that
I was able to be at the Olympics with almost
every country on Earth represented in some
way or another, in some sport, all staying
in one village.
It's amazing to be able to meet all these
people and to experience all these different
cultures.
Fencing is a game of physical chess.
You have to be able to out-move your opponent
on the strip with speed, agility, and endurance.
But you also have to be able to outsmart them,
to trick them.
Being able to make split-second decision off
of little, tiny pieces of information in the
sport, that also helps in real life.
Our best ability as fencers is our ability
to compartmentalize all the stuff we're doing
in our life.
To wake up in the morning, go to classes,
do work, come straight to practice.
To lift for a few hours, to work as a team,
cool down, we have a team dinner.
And then go straight to the library or straight
to your room to do homework or study for tests
or writing essays, it all helps us improve
our academic as well as our athletic performance.
The fact that I took a year off from school
and trained full-time, I believed that if
I put in all the time and effort, I would
make it to the next level to the Olympic level.
That definitely gave me the confidence to
believe that, now I'm back at school, if I
work hard enough in school, I can reach certain
academic levels.
I'm hoping that the rest of my time here can
help prepare me physically as well as mentally.
I'm just excited for another few years here
to grow as an athlete and as a person before
I start my journey to the next Olympics.